oh we go memory my name and we're back
and welcome to GTA 4 I never actually
played this game before but I want I
wanted to play because I found this mob
and it's hilarious
so yeah I'm a heart I'm Sarah Jessica
Parker that's what I am
oh here we go some paper just want to
see what burn me step aside lady howdy
oh I'm about to take it from your
project
that's right get up [ __ ] would ya I'm a
[ __ ] crab [ __ ] [ __ ] crap you
like that [ __ ] legs correct jack
that's right I'm a crab betcha oh yeah
thought I was a horse though I'm a crab
all right I'm out of here too many
places are protected step aside lady
step aside I'm driving this vehicle [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
oh no my dad a dog [ __ ] that's gonna
burn tomorrow oh this is my stop
huh I'm stuck No ah ah [ __ ] [ __ ] calm
down come ah
Oh what am i doing gotta get up on my
feet I mean my whose stop making fun of
me because I look like a heart I'm not
hard okay [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I got a run you should look good I
got a helmet and everything alright
let's see how I did way up what's the
matter you never seen the horse ride a
motorcycle before [ __ ] freak
step aside paper holy [ __ ] alright we
got
[ __ ] yeah it doesn't get any more badass
than this alright epic slide Oh Sarah
Jessica power ah ah [ __ ] hey can I swim
please Sam I can swim well my buckets
win no sir of course this is how you
swim guys go and sauna I'm beautiful
parrot yes you're such a beautiful
swimmer what's going on man Sarah Sarah
what are you doing you're not a
submarine Sarah shut up
get up there finally such a stupid [ __ ]
all right let's see what more adventures
we can go to Sarah horses don't fly
Sarah
we're dead badger [ __ ] shut up Sarah so
stupid so stupid
whoa are you okay there Sarah oh she's
fine all right
that's good kiss me ah ah you realize
how much that hurt ah [ __ ] I want the
cab I want the cab I want to cabin
number right
I want the cab I want scab that what
cabs mine cabins mine cabs mine are you
doing that sir get out of the [ __ ]
vehicle that's right you just got mugged
by a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
don't you dare don't you dare touch me
what are you a doll you want to fight
you want to fight you want to find no
that's right come here come here you
want to fight you want to [ __ ] fight
you want a [ __ ] fight come [ __ ]
back here I [ __ ] dare you
well you are back but stay down stay
down stay down Dana I am I like this oh
yeah make a stack all right yay hi Scott
but Gama hurts everyday I'm a harsh
[ __ ] [ __ ] just don't realize
they don't know what they're missing
sorry about that lady what sorry what
alright alright alright
sorry that's sorry
I have places to go step Adam sorry
about that
ah [ __ ] what alright dude what down whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa shell animal
abuse right there haha it's a horse with
a rocket launcher
oh it's horse smacking time whoa [ __ ]
spank all idea
you [ __ ] I tell you call me a heart
oh you too oh you too
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] now you're a
horse I'm not a [ __ ] horse okay you
made me [ __ ] do it
you made me [ __ ] doing you made me do
it
alright press whoa I'm gonna hit the
deficit but like videos if you enjoyed
I'm sorry it was really weird so like
that I wanted to tell somebody
via whatever
if other people have uploaded a video of
the same game you're not allowed to play
at you are copying the yeah you're
[ __ ] copying all of them